on a les photos s'y coller un vent c'est
mon dernier jour de gloire donc allez-y
profitez-en bien tout le monde étant là
on va pouvoir si vous voulez vous
asseoir rien n'a pas pour longtemps
devant accueillir les ministres je
voudrais pas gâcher son voyage j'ai une
contracture rck leur disant je t'en veux
bien donc on y va aller alors vous
éteignez les téléphones bon alors merci
à tous d'être là ce matin je suis pas
sûr d'avoir eu recours dès ses 12 années
au autant de presse autour de moi merci
à ce qu respecter mon silence pour les
autres sont seuls responsables de ce
qu'ils disent je les salue aussi bien le
temps d'aimer voulait que cette
déclaration son empreinte d'un peu de
dignité
bien sûr d'émotion aussi l'imagier et je
pense que la politique mérite trois
vertus si tout est confus en avant la
lucidité l'éthique et le courage
lucide sur une situation sur ses débuts
en politique éthique parce que la
politique sans éthique de la cosmétique
duris multi
puis courageux parce que même quand on
pourrait être en situation prendre une
décision qui risque de 2 crée de la
déception même parfois au contraire
abaissement des envies mais c'est un peu
difficile aussi et j'ai voulu donner un
peu de solennité à cette décision
d'abord pour pour montrer que c'est une
décision libre je le redirai mais aussi
que les fêtes pour préparer l'avenir
elle fait pour permettre force cantons
qu'elle j'appartiens ne se mettre en
ordre de bataille pour aller à cette
élection difficile mais importante
surtout avec les régions de maintenant
avec la grande région de maintenant donc
je souhaitais donner le temps nécessaire
et c'est fait six morts mais beaucoup
étaient pressés quel empressement alors
que je me souviens quand même qu'en 2004
nous avions commencé cette campagne
trois mois et demi avant même de janvier
candidature on vous fait cinq mois avant
et qu'on va commencer la campagne en
2010 en février mais bon j'entends bien
qu'il faut de l'actualité quotidienne et
j'essayais de prendre le temps
nécessaire celui du calendrier sur lui
la réflexion la bonne personnel vous
avez dit tout ce que j'étais
j'avais le choix entre la passion et la
raison ce choix je lui jusqu'à ce week
end jusqu'à ce week-end et c'est après
avoir contré le chef de l'état samedi
j'ai pris cette décision que je vous
donne maintenant alors ne vous
réjouissez pas trop vite je ne prends
pas ma retraite je prends de la hauteur
ni jean prend de la hauteur
le tout le temps et est toujours le
temps le lieu est toujours le lieu est
ce qui est réel ne l'est que pour
atteindre ne prenez pas de la poésie et
ne l'est que pour un lieu ils font
saisir la mesure je change de rôle
je ne change pas de vie et je ne change
pas d'actions l'action politique n'est
pas qu'une affaire de mandat elle est un
mouvement continu vers l'avant que nous
devons accompagner 12 ans de présidence
à la région c'est rare ça n'a jamais été
fait nous on pense qu'on atteindra la
deuxième année mois de mars prochain
donc manquera trois mois pour 12 ans ci
ra
si bien à l'heure où les français
souhaitent changement et surtout parfois
souvent même des changements de tête
il faut savoir et je souhaite pouvoir
ouvrir la porte au renouvellement
beaucoup et mes amis sont avec moi
aujourd'hui beaucoup incité à poursuivre
je les entends dire je les en remercie
j'y trouve une reconnaissance du travail
accompli avec mon équipe et lol déjà un
seul mot mais un grand merci à tous les
élus qui m'ont soutenu sans faille
pendant ses 12 ans à tous les militants
et à tous ceux qui nous ont aidés à
gagner les élections et puis à tous les
services de la région c'était vraiment
j'ai des services c'est la région sur
lesquels j'ai pu compter avec qui j'ai
pu travailler et avec qui nous avons pu
mener ensemble les actions ambitieuses
que nous sommes que nous avons menées je
pense que ce travail laissera des traces
qui sont mieux que des preuves des
repères pour l'avenir prenez les
tchèques connaît mais on essaiera quand
même pendant les six mois de montrer ce
que nous avons fait je ne dis pas tout
de suite
lire est ramenée en fera mais quand je
pense qu'on doit on faire en matière
scolaire de formation d'innovation des
colliers de transition énergétique de
santé de santé bien et d'autres je pense
qu'on pourra tirer ce bilan ces bilans
il est il aboutit à une décision qui est
libre d'auto plus difficile d'ailleurs
qu'il est libre en quittant la
présidence de la région à la fin de
cette année le 1er janvier
je n'ai aucun remords les regrets oui
qu'ils n'en avaient pas je pense avoir
des amis impulser
cette unification des deux soeurs
bourguignonne qui étaient séparés par
l'arbitraire de l'histoire cela
m'apparaissait une évidence tant réuni
nos deux régions pourront prétendre à
garder prix sur l'avenir tant divisés
elles entreront dans une spirale du
déclin unis elles réussiront divisée
elle décline ongles leur position
géographique leur équilibre rare dans un
monde urbain dynamique et un monde rural
si riche si savoir faire et ses
ressources avec la rigueur d'un quart no
l'imagination d'un sociétaire d'un
fourier les rêves d'un proudhon le génie
d'un vauban l'exigence démocratique et
sociale d'un considérant l'innovation
d'un effet le génie d'un pasteur tout le
terreau fécond et là pour nourrir un
projet d'un futur recomposée place et la
bourgogne franche comté sous le vent de
l'histoire
ce n'est pas une métaphore éoliennes le
cap des fermement fixées à une équipe
rajeunie et ouverte dans nourrir le
propos rené char 10 et notre héritage
serait mon prédécesseur il s'était
souvent rené char et c'était toujours
certains destins qui se reconnaîtront
moi j'ai relu revenir rené charles vii
ce week-end il dit notre héritage n'est
précédé d'aucun testament
il ne m'appartient pas de faire écran
aux nécessaire évolution puisque j'en
suis ans rené chort il voudrait suivre
sur une citation on ne peut se retirer
de la vie des autres et si l'essai soit
il ya un proverbe chinois que j'aime
bien et que voudrais partager avec vous
il y a un temps pour pêcher il y un
temps pour sécher les filets et aussi
pour les préparer et repréparer la pêche
le sénat a été créée comme une chambre
de réflexion un temps
d'approfondissement de débat un lieu d
co des collectivités territoriales je
siègerai au sénat avec la bourgogne
franche comté au coeur qui défendrait
les grands dossiers de notre belle
région
notamment je souhaite dans le même temps
non pas d'abord poursuivre les
politiques avec l'âpreté nécessaire mais
aussi avec l'idée de travailler donc de
vrais sujets de grands sujets poursuit
mon action dans le domaine de la santé
par exemple de la lutte contre le cancer
au paul contre le cancer pardon je
préside le cancéropole j'aimerais
m'impliquer dans avec mes amis et donc
par là même essayé de m'appliquer dans
les dossiers sentais tellement
nécessaire à nos territoires occupés de
la transition énergétique
bien entendu participer mais à ma place
à nouveau au développement économique de
la ville
j'ai pris cette décision pour des
raisons éthiques politiques et
personnelles éthique parce que même si
j'ai défendu le doubs le double mandat
j'ai toujours dit par exemple de mandat
je dois faire avec le fait que dans un
an dans 15 mois le non-cumul
s'appliquera
pourquoi partir à une élection en
promettant aux électeurs monts et
merveilles alors qu'on sait très bien
que deux mois après il faudra choisir
éthique parce que je pense qu'en
politique on l'a dit mais bien la
formule ne veut pas dire ce que l'on
fait faire ce qu'on me dit rang j'ai
toujours pensé qu'il fallait pas faire
le mandat de trop qu'il fallait sortir
par le haut et non pas se laisser
imposer comme certains jeux les vues je
préfère aujourd'hui être en situation et
croyez que j'ai un petit peu de plaisir
beaucoup de plaisir à savoir que
j'aurais pu encore être candidat et que
beaucoup auraient soutenu mais je sais
qu'on prenait à vis aujourd'hui je vais
faire de la peine à certains je sais que
je vais décevoir
d'autres mais je sais aussi que ceux qui
ceux qui m'aiment bien ce qu'ils
m'apprécient comprendront
ce choix même si leur pareil pour eux
difficile compte tenu de l'approché du
combat qui nous attend deuxième raison
est les politiques et les politiques
pour partir à cette élection
je crois que la gauche devra être uni je
ne suis pas convaincu à titre personnel
d'être celui qui pourrait réunir
aujourd'hui et fort dodge
d'autres sont mieux placés que moi pour
réunir les trois composantes de la
majorité plurielle le feront sans doute
avec détermination et aussi et puis
politique parce que la tâche qui nous
attend au delà de cette période
électorale qui va être prenantes
ap difficile si vous êtes une période de
combat au delà de cela il ya l'immense
travail de la réunification et du
nouveau rôle des régions
nous allons terminer au sénat l'examen
de la loi note les propre et ans des
régions voient formidablement renforcer
et j'y ai participé parce que je crois à
la réalité et à l'avenir de la région
dans la répartition des étals
territoriaux dans notre pays
ça veut dire qu'il faudra se battre et
là je me battrai pour aider la région
parce que donner des compétences
nouvelles aux régions sans en assurer
aujourd'hui les moyens financiers c'est
le combat du futur budget c'est le
facteur de la prochaine loi de finances
la devenant leader dans le domaine
économique
peut-être même dans l'accompagnement des
demandeurs d'emploi vous imaginez les
moyens humains est nécessaire que cela
va solliciter
c'était il ya 500 chantiers en attente
il va falloir réunir les personnels il
va falloir réunir les politiques qui va
falloir les aujourd'hui elles sont
différentes
va falloir demain et trouver les
financements dans une période de finance
aussi où les économies sont la règle
troisième raison est le personnel
reprenait que la dernière élection en
2010 j'étais le doyen d'âge de cette
assemblée
ça m'avait déjà un peu marqué ça vous a
pas échappé
maintenant je pense que faut savoir je
voulais d'y prendre un peu de hauteur
être lucide et considéré qu' après 40
ans 40 ans il me reste encore si au bout
58 sénat 40 ans de vie politique qu'il
est nécessaire de faire la place et
d'accompagner et de passer même s'il
s'agit pas j'avais du talent d'un
testament et accompagner les nouvelles
équipes
bon je vais m'engager dans ce combat en
disant personnel personnel aussi parce
que faire une campagne survie
département pendant les quatre mois qui
viennent qui viennent ensuite occupé
département cdg celle prononcée ces dix
ans fait 100 120 10 km par an chaque
année à travers la région bourgogne jean
connaît tous les recoins j'en connais
beaucoup de beaucoup de lieux
je connais aussi tellement de gens et
qui j'ai lu et les liens de sympathie
d'amitié
donc je pense que ça va être aussi ça
moment où va devoir au sénat s'impliquer
beaucoup vous savez qu'on devait être de
voir trois jours par semaine au sénat
maintenant donc faire trois jours par
semaine au sénat quatre jours à la
région je ne suis pas sûr que mes forces
deux jeunes hommes politiques puissent
encore mais permettre même si j'ai
confiance encore en mai mais talent
sportif mais je crois que félicite donc
ces personnes impossible puis personnel
parce que j'ai toujours pensé qu'en
politique il fallait avoir le courage
que ça m'a demandé de courage de prendre
cette décision aujourd'hui je la prends
j'espère que la bourgogne franche comté
réalisera les voeux que nous avons fait
pour elle en la construisant je souhaite
et je le dis ici qu' il n'y ait pas
d'ambiguïté sur l'organisation des
territoires qui ne peut pas y avoir
d'injustice midi quitter ni d'iniquité
inégalités et que les services doivent
être répartis sur nos deux territoires
qu'il n'y ait pas deux de migration
humaine exigent tous les services mais
je pense je pense je le dis ici que la
logique peut être respectée comme elle
l'est dans d'autres territoires
aujourd'hui que la red dijon 2
être la capitale régionale et dijon doit
même être à mon avis le siège de la
région il est mais je pense que les
services faudra territorialisée faudra
en aucun cas
en aucun cas je le dis ici que besançon
perdent c'est à dire qu'il ne blesse
mais noblesse de son sa position mais
aussi la richesse humaine qu'elle
détient aujourd'hui nous ferons en sorte
avec les services de l'état pour qu'il
en soit ainsi
voilà c'est pas dit souhaiter vous c'est
un ski nancy
merci à tous nous reste quelques
instants si vous voulez bien poser
quelques questions s'il répondrait mais
je pense avoir dit l'essentiel non merci
d'être venu parce que près tous
quelqu'un parmi vous m'avez dit mais
vous n'allez pas faire une réunion pour
dire que oui
y aller pas non pour dire que vous y
allez gentil de me l'avoir dit merci à
sa merci qu'ils aient respecté tout bon
j'ai quand même voulu
prenons une décision qui met douloureuse
et courageuse je vais donner un petit
peu cette spécialité ce matin parce que
d'abord je suis ému il ya aussi par de
tristesse qui vous échappent pas à voler
mais aussi une part d'ambition
c'est à dire de fierté du travail
accompli et lui de d'espoir dans
l'avenir je me tourne maintenant vers
l'est vers les nouveaux chantiers dans
lequel je vais m'appliquer totalement je
ne prends pas ma retraite je prends de
la hauteur et je reste un animal
politique tel que vous l'avez quote
merci merci à tous alors une question
pour l'instant il ya une procédure
une procédure qui est en route et le
cocktail qui a déclaré avec qui je
travaille bien depuis des années que
j'ai quand j'ai lancé le processus de la
réunification
c'était au mois de janvier ces tomates
janvier 2014
bien avant même que le président parle
ou que promis 100 par an et j'avais dit
simplement c'est l'idée j'en avais
avertis marie-guite dufay je te dire que
l a très vite pris le parent en mesurant
pour elle mais une mesure recueille les
difficultés que celles du cause et
puisque je connais bien l'état d'esprit
certaine réticence qui s'exprime en
franche comté qui sont pas d'être être
dépassé maintenant mais elle est
candidate aujourd'hui si elle est
candidate et qu'elle désigne et je leur
a tout mon soutien bien entendu le reste
rien si elle est désignée pas
j'ai cru comprendre que c'était le choix
c'était le choix
les hautes autorités de l'état et des
femmes et sortantes là aussi travail
accompli un travail remarquable
ramos ou tipi dans les positions
expliqué
non non pas du tout non non mon choix il
est libre ou non mais dites mais j'ai
aussi consulté jeudi
j'ai dit voilà j'ai dit samedi soir j'ai
des tas quelle est ma position on a
convenu ensemble
d'abord il a respecté et qu'ensuite le
fait d'ouvrir la possibilité d'une autre
femme que d'autres candidates de le
faire ça pouvait citer aussi la marque
des partis de pouvoir accompagner les
familles dans ces combats
peut-être compte rapatrier ce que je
peux dire c'est que sondage qui
appartient pas triste que je n'ai jamais
écrit d'ailleurs un don m'a donné les
éléments ne change en rien la donne en
ce sens que peut-être aurait-il pu
afflué s'ils avaient marqué profondément
que j'étais l'arrco donne pas comme tel
donc dans ces conditions me libère de
tout mais les angoisses
je serai candidat à soutenir ben alisme
et organisationnelles km il faudra pas y
avoir de tête d'abord je ne connais pas
alors qu'il est laid et tête de liste
dans le département de progrès donc
parmi eux peut-être un deux
s'imposera-t-il comme celui ça mais là
je ne les connais pas je sais pas qui
était de liste gagne un franc je ne sais
pas qui tu deviens saône et loire je ne
sais pas peut-être le sais je sais pas
mais n'ont donc jamais ne pas y avoir
deux chefs un cotillard le jeune titre
en est ce qu'on l'a fait par le passé
nos lauréats directeur qui aura
directeur de campagne
en face il y avait qu'est ce qu'elle
avait de social réunion deux régions non
on est unis c'est la façon on ne va pas
continuer le dualisme tout le temps fava
qui aurait pour d'accueil en équilibre
il ya un équilibre sur des sièges et un
équilibre démographique qui respecte et
on payera penny candidate candidats et
puis il y aura un directeur de campagne
je pense qu'elle peut être dans des
territoires et d'autres personnes ça va
j'ai pas été trop lyrique sa voix quand
même
pas mal quand même merci à tous